so this talk is kind of a mix between
previous talks that I had and I tried to
put them together it's kind of like
story experience Python physics talk and
I tried to remove most of the scary
parts
I just left one there just for you to to
get more more close to the topic in
general so M so this talk is mainly
about the experience that I have doing
astrophysics there may be HD it was
mainly doing playing around with stars
black holes and of course
Python if you have any question of
course you can find me there later or
you can write on the chat so umm I study
computer science and I started studying
2006 and situation back there at least
for me was that I was really into
scripting I was doing anything with Perl
- and Python was still something that at
least in my universe he was not really
widely used one of the nice thing is I
remember reading when 91 points
zero was out and it was like not cool so
something about erase and stuff but I
didn't even carry much so well the
jurors were advancing in 2009 M Python 3
was already out but of course we zero
and still at least in my university they
were like you know Perl people over the
place writing complicated lines and
other people that we started to look
into parallel computing but of course
we're having a C background and back
then I remember that I went to a
conference that there was the authors of
MPI for PI and PI CUDA were giving some
talks and I was like hmm
so apparently you can use this Python
thingy in a more professional way and
maybe at the end of this year or in the
middle of these years there was also
this kind of I don't want to call it
fight but dispute between the angle on
Ruby on Rails because of you know
everyone wanted to do the scripting
things and web applications and so
Python was at least in my world was
starting to become more popular
so when I started my studies at the PhD
more or less I mean hi python was still
not a thing around my the people that I
had in the uni not books with no and I
remember I was just an I Python because
it was kind of nice to have told a
history of the commands that you were
using but in any case Bundys was like
what no but I think that it was Oh point
something I don't remember the diversion
of Candice and this friend of mine that
was doing some forecast simulations who
told me like oh there was a new thing
called scikit-learn and it was like yeah
well whatever I mean pandas I could
learn yet another Python module that
will not become popular right so in this
situation it was like kind of really
again I want to say completely against
but like Python was maybe some toy to
play around with but in any case is
something that I really like I mean it
was really simple and other people were
really keen into understanding what was
going on so okay I had some experience I
was teaching some Python basic but okay
so maybe I can use this so when I
started to start I decided to start
astrophysics and just a disclaimer when
people talk about strana me
serving is natural science in general
sometimes people also refer to astronomy
with observational astronomy so people
go into telescopes or maybe manipulating
some radio telescope just just antennas
and when we are talking about
astrophysics is something that is inside
astronomy um and we you can't kind of
like we're studying the nature of all
these celestial objects there and even
if it even though it's called passive
physics it's used a lot of chemistry too
so that's kind of like the the main
difference of astronomy NASA physics if
you have a question that is on the
screen at the moment I think that I will
literally jump out of the window
astrology has nothing to do which is
field
it's a pseudoscience so let's go wires
of physics to be honest I mean I
whenever
finishing I was really into high
performance computing and I got really
tied into programming GPUs back then I
were using CUDA maybe most of you have
heard and now you can like write one
line and suddenly you have your machine
learning models on the GPU and but there
they was really cool because see
extensions you were handling memory by
hand and I don't know I was really into
C so it was a really cool things to do
but most importantly there was this talk
a since I have the desk of my way I will
just show it so there was a media was
showing some stuff there at some point
and they show these simulations I hope
that you were following it looks really
cool right I mean I know when I saw this
thing in a conference in a video
conference and I was like oh my god how
could you can do that I want to do that
so this thing was called embody problem
and then I started to read about it so
after reading and everything okay I was
I fact all my things I write here in
Germany and I was I was expecting from
you know a Research Institute widely
know with research that stuff from my
computer science background it was like
a so they will have some perfect control
systems software with documentation
there's implementation details I was
kind of like willing to use all the
tools and secure weapons that I had for
for my studies right I mean robust
frameworks using the latest programming
languages that helped me a surface is
doing stuff and of course mainly science
so what I found when I arrived there and
of course this is really specific to my
Center but after talking with many
people was kind of like same scenario
but back in 2012
so people with sharing code with a zip
file so tarji sets and until today one
of the most important people with this
embody problem that I show you is that
they have their own website doesn't
matter if you cannot read but and they
have all the versions there so this is
version control as a la astrophysicist
and okay so fair enough yeah well can
don't let's compile some stuff um there
were no documentation whatsoever I mean
some comments were like iron I remember
still some comments like we are using
three quarters here because it's
impairing empirically it works but we
don't have a reason for it and stuff
like that
all our simulation coder was using
scientific papers of course
implementation details or documentation
on how to use it you know this nice like
QuickStart stuff
it was completely missing but there were
many scientific papers that were high
highlighting the mathematical models
behind so you can get a general idea
there was no frameworks be honest and
this programming language dominating
Astrophysical listen my Center was
Fortran there were some people rave
enough to do stuff in bash to automate
stuff and I met a couple of people they
were playing around with Python but they
were just not using it if you're not
familiar with Fortran first of all you
are really lucky but if not I just want
to share so for example here you have
some Fortran code if you are not
familiar with it it's really painful at
least for me to to read it and it's a
language that even though it's fast and
whatever it's really not kind of like
approachable but it was signed so that
was cool so okay so I was mentioning
before the embody problem and I wanted
to work and it's starting so there will
be some math now ahead but don't worry
about it
I will try to explain everything there
so the important problem is that mainly
solving this equation there that you see
which maybe could seem for you a little
bit hard but just believe me it's not
you will see a prototype afterwards it's
300 years old and this comes from Newton
this is Newtonian physics so this is
nothing else let the interaction of two
what is there you have R which is just
distance or the vector distance and you
have here acceleration two dots is
because it's derived twice so you'll
derive those a position then you have a
velocity and the acceleration
and usually this is the description of
or the physics behind things are called
stellar systems or maybe you heard about
globular clusters or maybe you saw some
nice pictures that the one on the on the
right like many stars together so this
is a globular cluster okay so I started
to read a little bit about and then they
were like many different approaches to
solve this simple equation they were
like things called three code there was
like kind of like divide and conquer in
a hierarchical whale there was really
crazy extrapolation methods like the fmm
there was multiple methods and there was
a more naive approach that is just
applying the same formula that you saw
is called Derek summation so I thought
okay if I want to start let's go for the
Oh N squared so first of all reading all
these scientific papers and stuff was
kind of complicated so I needed
something by hand that kind of like was
easy to write easy to understand easy to
derive and try to play around with it so
I decided to use Python for everything
that I was prototyping and as you can
see the formula on the right then the
left it's nothing else that the formula
on the right I mean of course inside
formula calculation you have some
subtractions and maybe some
multiplication you have some structure
storing everything but this mainly it's
nothing else besides this so okay simple
enough so I decided it's okay I will so
stick with Python and try to use it with
many other approaches so I started to
use it mainly for intimation stuff
usually the systems the one this all
these starts together there are like
many theoretical things that you will
write about like how to generate the
initial conditions and I was using one
of these this called plumber sphere but
again just a formula that you get random
points and then you have this kind of
the same the same instructor so in the
meantime meantime I just want to
highlight that I mean when you say
astrophysics usually maybe what comes to
your mind is like I don't know people
doing real science like for example this
photo or like people doing real things
like in labs and stuff that's
experimental physics so
what is theoretical astrophysics is more
or less what we are all doing now
sitting behind a desk on a computer
running some you know some simulations
and stuff so so far is really simple
approach so in theory everyone here can
kind of start playing around with these
things but of course all the simulations
are quite demanding and you need to have
like access to giant clusters with
hundreds of nodes and stuff so another
thing that I did it was kind of
generating you know initial conditions
and also all this this is kind of an
example of a submission script so it's
just a bad script how to submit this to
the class the local class or I used to
have so many things start to repeat here
like for example okay I want 16 nodes I
have here 16 too so all these things
were automated and I had some magical
script that was generating these for a
range of course or number of particles
for this set of stars something else of
course was data processing and since I
was really beginning with Python I was
relying mostly on the OS model you know
at least the year and everything but
leaf was still another thing when I was
unpacking binary structures I was using
this truck model that I don't know if
many of you know it if you want to
handle binary data and the fancier thing
that I learned it was like if you were
using Nampa load Tex was kind of slower
compared to the gen from tech so I I was
the Python expert because knowing that
but then you guys yeah but if you're
working with data and set whatever
pandas back there I was like I think at
a 1 2012 so was not silly thing and even
though many people start to use it I was
not really into trying new stuff because
of course I needed to finish experience
and everything so of course other really
important aspect is after you process
all your those data you can have nice
combination for a scientific paper like
using math 11 lattice and you can have
you know just random plots therefore
like following lot X s style so in this
case for example this is how the system
evolves and scale with different amount
of particles using of an MP this uses
I think it is MPI and is using multiple
GPUs and different systems so you see
they're scaling this is the number of
party so stuff like this was kind of
like kind of like an everyday thing so
pythons started to become my go-to tool
to automate stuff I was even at home
phone automating email sending because
there were some conference we were gonna
hang there were some some times that I
needed to send information inside I was
even using relying on Python to write
small scripts to send emails for example
I don't know if you know that you can
configure maybe your email or pop3
server and then just write mail - s
whatever and just write an email from
the command line but sadler that was
easily to automate but so far is like
yeah okay is that good so meeting a
couple of things and your life was easy
and stuff but it's kind of boring so far
so this was one of the most entertaining
thing that I started to use I didn't
know anything about OpenGL and I started
to roll write data visualization tool
from all these embody simulations as you
can see there it was one of the first
prototypes the tool then later on I
rewrote it in C++ but originally I was
running this with PI OpenGL and it was
really straightforward to kind of ended
up having this visualization which also
looks really nice I mean if I show you
all the plots but if you show you this
it was all cool some stars and points
and there was also some really things
that I started to use that map taught me
a lot and I started to do many and
custom plots so in this case it's a
simple plot I started to make some color
for some specific of the starts this is
again the same thing more or less that
we are looking at here and there is a
phenomena that I wanted to study at some
point it's like the the red dots maybe
you don't see the red but the dark
colored stars here they tend to use go
to the middle of the system in an in a
phenomena that is called core collapse
so I did this with map to live and then
I had some animation at some point that
I couldn't find him and then I had like
you know after a couple of time step I
can easily see all the darker things
there so I was really hugging in too
much
leave there are many things that were
not possible to do so and I guess that
was the idea that many other frameworks
started to born from what believe paddy
I mean the the belief scripts that I had
was really but it was really cool
because nobody else was able to do this
they using new plot and stuff but it was
really complicated and not portable and
I don't know if I started to feel like
Python was really like my element like
main weapon for solving anything that
any problem that I had to render size so
that was a part of stars so regarding
all the black hole part of the story and
black holes are still a mystery and I
maybe you remember from media some news
about it but still we know nothing and
think about your article surfaces
astrophysics is that we write papers we
have stuff and maybe in couple maybe in
tens maybe hundreds of years someone
will say um no you were wrong this was
original but so far we have no idea what
is inside black holes that's why we
still call it a black hole but maybe
there is some interesting particle
inside so I just usually I interact
about what people up since we don't we
cannot interact much I just wanted to
see if some of you knew this photo I
will expect maybe some hands on the
audience but in any case this is like oh
so this is an experimental facility that
has these really long arms and they were
sending laser beams to each arm at the
same time so imagine something like
coming from here and then from there and
then there were some mirrors at the
extreme and the thing was coming back
and what they were measuring was that
when the laser came back did they were
at the same time and we are talking
about here of like precision of 10 to
the minus 20 something meters so it's
really really something really crazy
small maybe this is not familiar with
you but maybe they were gravitational
wave it's more familiar to you a couple
of years ago there was a Nobel Prize and
physics was a gravitational ways so what
they do
tact was a simple gravitational wave
that was coming from the collision
between two blocks so when two massive
objects in the universe like black holes
or neutron star maybe heard of a Newton
stars collide they are so massive that
they freeze so much energy that they
disrupt space-time so this means like
you can imagine this simply like imagine
a lake and you throw a stone and then
you see all these ripples going around
it is the same but with space them so
what what does this means if I am
receiving a gravitational wave then my
my head will start to elongate and then
to the sides like an effect like a
spring effect but of course this effect
this elongation is something as you can
see maybe here numbers ten to the minus
twenty something meters so it's
something really really small so you
really need precise so so hey like of
course is located here on earth but
there are many other projects that are
coming in the future and one of this I
just wanted to highlight it this this
one here down I don't hear that I want
to show you a video about it it's called
Lisa so the laser laser interferometer
space so I know you have no sound but
just imagine really like inception most
music going on like you know but the
idea of this is grabbing the same let me
just pause here briefly is grabbing the
same idea that we have here on earth but
on space so they we want to go crazy and
launch the space rocket and once the
space rocket is up they will start to
you know release all these different
satellites and in all these satellites
if you see there they are like 23 they
have been some modification of these
projects but they will be around space
they will start to communicate between
them and they will start to see okay so
where do we need to connect and then
shooting lasers the I know this sounds
like Star Wars stuff but
not believe me and then they have these
self-regulating things millions of
kilometers between the lasers they will
set receive everything and is it okay
sure we acquire the signal and then we
will have the fixed configuration that
we will need to maintain and these three
satellites will start to nothing else
that go around earth and start to
observe everything that we have around
so the same thing that we managed you
can see there there is a following Earth
orbit I just want to return that posit I
will see to see like many many many many
more like a little species and corners
in the universe that the project that I
will briefly describing before I can so
this is a mission that is already
accepted is for 2030 for yes this space
mission takes time but it is something
that will be really amazing that maybe
you will remember this talk and in a
couple of years will say oh my god this
was the thing that was in PI data but I
am probably that one that mission is out
physics will change completely so also
another really interesting think about
black holes that use all this event
horizon telescope and pictures that you
can see there that that's it's a picture
to back about what we see there all the
brightness is just photons are trapped
into the the event horizon of course of
the black hole and if you're interested
in these there was a real sci-fi talk
last year really interesting talk live
by sorry zone so maybe you can go there
and see there it's called in the shadow
of battle really interesting stuff I
really invited to go there but yeah so
let's go back a little bit back to
reality so what I was doing with black
holes was like you we know Newtonian
physics so the physics that you learn
may be in high school or university if
you did something similar things moving
around orbits and as you can see this
animated gif you have heard that it's
kind of a little bit faster when you go
to the sound and slower this is what's
called Newtonian physics everything was
calculated here on earth but as soon as
we started to see things outside earth
we start to really understand that maybe
were wrong so have you heard about Mary
curry of course the planet hey I don't
know if any one of you know any
particular thing about mercury even of
course this is the first planet of a
solar system called Sun but did you know
that the orbit of mercury is processing
so you start here and then it's kind of
like tilting little by little and then
we have this kind of like rose shape so
nobody knew why this was happening until
of course there were some more research
and people who start to understand that
this was a new physics so this was
post-newtonian physics i for this thing
you have a set of formulas that you can
apply and in the case of if you have
like two stars whirling around or black
holes or whatever just two things
wheeling around you can get some effects
like this one for example you see the
two different lines are two different
objects in this case the lines resemble
the black hole that is really close to
merge with another one because they will
go wearing around and it will go
together and together and together at
some point would they will merge and I
will generate this gravitational wave
that I was mentioning so you can model
these things there are some formulas
that you can get are approximations to
this but how do we really calculate
these things and for this I just want to
all to take a deep breath because we
will see some weird things on the screen
now okay so we start from this point
this is Newtonian physics this is the
same equation that I will show you
before but written in a different way
the precession that we know from mercury
it comes from the first person Tony on
terms there is another term the second
that is called e energy and there's the
third that is related to all the spins
of stars so how do you calculate the
first ball soon enter this is equation
we have speed of light there many
different fraction as everything okay
this is the second the second was so
complicated and difficult to understand
that you need a correction so they
amended two point five which is a
correction to the other one and then you
go to spin yeah
formula like this and I'm sorry but it's
not complete so you need the second part
of the formula so it's really and then
you have the correction of that spin so
and then again there was not the whole
formula so these formulas will real
thing and I needed to work with it for
me at least it's impossible to start
debugging something inside a huge
framework so I needed something easy to
do it so that's why I decided to go with
pipe and all these systems relied on the
energy conservation so this is just
acceleration of particles but if you
want to go to energy you need to be
consistent and also consider these
things into the energy likely for that
the equations were not really big but
still there is a lot of things going on
there I don't expect you to even kind of
like try to read these things so this is
real I mean I use this in simulation if
the animation that you saw before this
kind of rose like I implemented it and
you can see here this is the final
implementation in C++
they have posted onion terms 1 2 3 and
since I was working with the integration
system that was working with the
derivative of the acceleration I ended
up having these things again I don't
expect you and I don't wish you to ever
leave back these things do is this thing
in C++ as this was really complicated
for me so I needed to use Python and
without Python I think that I would be
unable to even understand if this thing
was working or not
so it was really a live server because
even complex form like this you can
writing in a simple way and trying to
understand so yeah that's enough for
maybe a couple of simulations but it's
this a real scenario I mean when we see
the skies or the news we see really nice
pictures out there and all these nice
pictures that showed colors that comes
from complex solutions so in this case I
was also using an existing piece of
software written C called
gadget and this was a smooth particle
hydrodynamics code sounds really
complicated but your nut shell is let's
have your moving point
and put some gas on it and some fluid
dynamics inside assistance so I was
referring to these pictures and you can
see here this is a really nice
simulation of two galaxies colliding the
simulation of this animation is based on
smooth particle idle dynamics so in that
case all the things that you see around
these bright spots is gas because gas
feed stars and then stars can go grow a
grow and grow and even black holes can
even get larger by eating stars but how
do black to eat stars this is something
that also was really mind-blowing for me
we don't know we assume we have
different approaches to understand this
there are different things color for
example rocha love that it's kind of
like some celestial mechanics
calculations that you can can at least
eight or infinite symbol that it depends
of how massive the optics are there are
some people that really don't care much
about this okay I will define a radius
on this black hole and everything that
enters it will be swallowed by the the
black hole and there are other
approaches that say eh everything that
is bound to the black hole so this means
that the energy is interactive strongly
with it it will be I created I created
this is a world for eating of course we
don't use eating in papers so there was
a lot of again different scenarios in
configuration how to play around with a
gas but still I was generating static
thoughts about so these are some
pictures of many simulations that I run
the simulation took months there all
these orange jell-o I don't know how
good is your screen are just gas
particles and these are millions of test
particles we ran around so since I was
usually suffering with this I really
needed to have something more visual and
then with Python I was able to make
something more nice which is of course
an animation so here you can see two
black holes rotate in the middle hey I
was asleep and then I started to do this
really cool experience that was drawing
gas clouds to the black the binary all
these the bright spots that you are
sitting on the screen are areas where
new stars can be born so in simulations
like this you can see if I have two
black holes I will start generating
stars you can see also let me pass this
you can see also some maybe here you can
see some it struck oh my god
sorry this one you can see some
instructors around the black hole soo
so for example there you can see some
dense areas around it so there is so
many applications here that when we
ended up having these simulations that
that we didn't know where to start and
we ended up like having two papers and
like ideas for all the like four papers
but we we notice all these things
because of this animations made with
Python of course some people were
looking at the plots but usually plots
were not about the whole evolution and
all simulation we will look in
specifically of these animations made
with Python and it was really helpful to
understand so this is another another
simulation that I just want to just show
you that things are kind of different in
this case the clouds are being thrown in
a counterclockwise sorry in clockwise
while the black holes are
counterclockwise so you see some kind of
ring there that is being formed this is
really cool and it's a really a nice
ring that I was really happy about it
but it gets destroyed now when this new
cloud and see no ring anymore so there
was many conclusions of course that I
want to go into details but structures
were not really stables in this but
again there are many things there and a
thing that I still have multiple clouds
if you are really interesting to see
more movies about these things if you go
to multiple clouds that XY set I have
all the videos there are the simulations
if you're interested you can go there so
when I started working with these things
and
most of these things were little scripts
people that knew people that were
writing Python scripts that do something
reading the snapshots of some program
generating these nice animation and so
on and so forth another use of Python
back then was people wrapping around see
libraries that we saw before MPI stuff a
CUDA and there were people that wanted
to go forward and it was a really nice
project spending and I just recently
check it and it's really really a
willable at the moment it's called Muse
so we can use their go and Muse code to
get a value so this kind of glue of many
Astrophysical pieces of code in one
place you can interact with different
simulations that are doing many stuff
and even to my surprise last year Pike
on earth listen to many people doing
different thing with CUDA
and GPU computing that I thought it was
only PI CUDA but now there was coop I
Jax Rapids there are so many no new
things at the moment that I think of
this an area's really prominent and
helpful at the moment but this was
before right so what do we have now I
think that what num focus is doing in
general is for me is the second boost of
Python what do we needed in general I
mean scientists over the world now I
think that they can easily start setting
up Jupiter notebooks and maybe you know
using pandas numpy whatever if you are
more into simulations with Monte Carlo
Markov chain things or maybe analytical
mathematics that things that you can do
with proprietary software like mat lab
and stuff you can still do it would
fight and of course there's also a
surprise there is a project that when I
heard about last year I look at it and
it was delightful to read there is a lot
of tutorials and documentation and I
will have loved to have that thing
before I started studying so I really
believe that if we know that the first
rise of Python was a well second make
the first one of course their release
but the angle kind of like position
Python out there then focus and science
in general is kind of position in Python
again as a de facto solution I'm really
curious to see in the next year like
what is the next step so some people is
saying that maybe Mobile is the future
Python
maybe webassembly maybe I don't know
writing Python and running everywhere
and just frustrated by microcontrollers
or whatever but really cares about so
yeah I mean that's it I really hope that
it was not too boring or too deep or
maybe too brief for your taste but I
would be more than happy to answer some
questions now if you have some other
questions that you don't want to ask now
you can reach me there and Twitter or
whatever at the moment I am NOT doing
science but that's I think it's topic
for another talk but yeah I think that I
will be gladly to see like if there are
some questions or something Thanks let's
say okay so a new question I guess no
questions I guess so well I tried to
minimize all the formulas and stuff but
in any case my information that was
there so any person with her and some
questions can write me thank you I would
you mentioned a lot like using Python I
probably would have yeah well the
problem is that when I I had a detail
but I started to remove slides because
it was mostly Python code and I was not
sure if there was but yeah maybe that
you ended up using just pretty much like
as you said numpy and just a basic
Python stuff and everything else from
scratch lost your voice
why did you I amuse myself just to hear
you and then I couldn't unmute me so
yeah and everything that I was using
there was numpy ends of my studies I
started to work with Python also with
pandas and it was like oh [ __ ] so why
didn't try this before but I yeah mainly
all the computational self was numpy by
CUDA I read eat some pie and there was
not pie in c3 but it was another Monte
Carlo Markov chain module to do some
want a common stuff yeah awesome I guess
we don't have questions I would I'm
going to allow people to unmute now and
stop recording